everybody oh shit sorry wait there we go hello everybody
hello oh let me so i'm all over the place right now um i
came back to grab a banana i was just like i think i set
everything up maybe i'm just gonna i'm gonna grab a banana
real quick um but yes uh i had a little dokey moment uh a
couple of days ago um i forgot to tell the story but um but
like the end of the story like let me speed run all the way
to the end of the story um i now own uh three three what are
they called like the little three like stacks of bananas
three bushels of bananas um because well i was like i i
don't want to have some bananas I'm craving some bananas.
And I thought I was ordering three pieces.
Because I was like three bunches.
I was going to say, what is the plural form of bananas?
Like when you're in the group and together.
Because you know how like a group of crows are together.
They're called a murder of crows.
Or like a murder or some shit.
So three bunches of bananas.
So how that ended up happening was because I was craving
bananas.
And, you know, I was Uber eating, Uber eating bananas
because the closest grocery store is pretty far away from
me.
And so I was just like, you know, I was like, wow, $1 for a
banana for a $1 and $1 for bananas?
That's pretty cheap.
I'm going to grab three bananas.
I don't remember.
The thing is I forgot how much bananas are supposed to cost.
So I was like, $3 for three bananas?
That seemed all right.
That seems pretty fair.
and what a deal I was just like I don't remember but I
bought banana in so fucking long the thing is I haven't
bought a banana in so long so I was thinking like I know how
much water costs so I was just like you know you know one
bottle of water like one bottle of water is like one dollar
something same with a can of coke you know like Arizona
green tea is 99 cents for one can of oh yeah yeah one dollar
for one banana that seems right and then and then you know
you know the the grocery bag came along and I was like wow
that looks really heavy why does the why does this bag look
really heavy I looked down and it was three three bushels of
bananas three bunches of Oh,
how much could a banana cost me?
Nexi, thank you for the super chat.
I was like, that's a lot of bananas.
So now I'm slowly trying to, I'm slowly trying to go
through, I think how many bananas are in one stack?
Like 6, like 6, 12.
I think I'm slowly trying to go through 18 bananas right
now.
I don't think I'm going to make it though.
Because the thing is, I'm going to be on vacation next week,
so I'm going to have at least 10 Ryan bananas in the end.
Maybe.
I hope, like, maybe I can get it to 8.
This is so a rest of development, Lucille moment for you.
Gavin, do you have a super chat?
Thank you, thank you.
No, everyone knows I'm going to be on vacation, so it's
because I won't be streaming when I'm on vacation, so it's
not like, it'll be like, it's like, she disappeared, where
did she go?
But I won't say exactly when, but my vacation does start
next week.
I don't know if I will be streaming on my vacation.
I might do, I will give updates and stuff on Twitter, but
most likely, I might do one stream.
There might just be one stream when I'm on vacation.
but that's gonna be it.
Cause I wanna actually have a vacation cause it has been a
while since I have a vacation vacation cause all my, oh, to
be fair, this, yeah, it's been a while since I've had a
vacation vacation.
So I'm gonna enjoy it while I can before I never had a
vacation again.
I'll be gone for around week.
I'll just say that.
I'll be around a week.
You guys will know when my vacation starts.
Um, so there won't be a schedule next week.
Um, I still will be, I'll still have my setup.
Um, I still have my setup for the beginning of the week.
But I won't make a schedule because, like I said, um, I'm
going to be on a vacation.
So, um, so I don't think I can make a schedule because when
I'm gone, I don't even know what's going to be going on.
So, I thought you already took a week off.
When I was sick, what do you mean?
I want a vacation where I'm healthy.
I want a vacation where I can be healthy and I don't do any
work.
That's not a vacation when I'm fucking dying in my bed.
As you used up all your sick days, you have to come back to
work.
uh and seven thing with super chat thank you thank you
smoothies banana bad bread you can even freeze right ones
into healthy popsicles thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you i don't know i don't make banana bread i feel
like baking stuff is so it is like hard because like it's
not like cooking where you can just pour whatever you want
on the ingredient like you can just pour whatever the fuck
you want like you know you pour a bit too much of one thing
it's fine it's just maybe a little saltier but when baking
um for baking you have to be like precise like you can't you
have to you have to be uh precise with your measurements or
you're gonna fuck it up banana bread is so it's the easiest
bread is it i mean it's the easiest bread
Less room for error, isn't it, compared to cooking?
Mm-hmm.
Yeah.
Because there's, because there's, like, chemistry.
And I, like, I cook more than I bake.
So, like, I'm, I also don't have any baking stuff in this
apartment, too, which I don't really want to buy, like,
utensils, like, buy pans and stuff for it.
To be fair.
measuring cups and i don't really i don't have any of that i
was like i'm not buying measuring cup for one banana bread
guys like spending spending at least 50 for something that
for bananas that cost me three dollars i i'd rather just um
the good thing is that dogs can eat bananas so like But
that's going to help out.
I don't know how much baking stuff costs, guys.
I'm just throwing numbers out.
No, it's $50 for a nice measuring cup.
For a mixture.
For a pan.
No, my talking is not just for the measuring cup, guys.
There's other stuff in baking.
I don't have a baking tray.
Or like a baking, like those glass pan things.
But the good thing is, dad's going to help me out getting
rid of all these bananas.
Because I need a lot of help right now.
There's a lot of bananas.
Funding towards measuring cups because you need to buy them
once, usually.
Sombra, thank you, thank you, thank you.
Let me put this away.
Oh yeah, dad's back from the dog sitter and look at this
ungrateful piece of shit who I love.
who I love very much but look at this guy's face when I
brought him back from the dog sitter like look at this guy
look at this fucking asshole he's like oh it's you he's so
spoiled he's like oh you're back I guess like wow I guess
wow got to Take me away from the dog city, huh?
He looks so upset.
That fucking side eye is like, wow.
Hello, mother.
Anyway, let's play.
Oh, what's the game fully called?
It's like poker night at the the hat simulator.
Sorry.
Uh, what is it called?
I forgot the name of the game.
Um, poker night the inventory.
Um, I've never played this game before.
Wait, poker night.
Wait, that is not correct.
Poker night at the inventory.
I was going to say that is not, that is not correct at the
inventory.
Let me fix that.
My manager made the winning room.
because I forgot to, and I was like, can you make the
waiting room?
I'm still in bed.
So that's not on me.
That is sort of on me because I was too lazy to get out of
bed.
That is sort of on me.
But he gave me the typo.
So thank you to my manager for having the waiting room.
for me um anyway um i've never got ever i've never played uh
i hired good at yet poker i don't know how to play poker so
we're gonna learn it live actually i finally guys i've never
played poker before so i always heard i've heard about this
game when it first came out um but obviously i never played
it because i don't know how i was underage and gambling's
legal uh oh boy yeah we're gonna learn poker at poker night
the inventory um and so um you know i never got a chance
that you play this and i was like too young uh to understand
this game uh and uh i've always wanted to try out because i
always hear people talk i remember always hearing people
talk about it when it first came up um it's fake it's only
legal if you get caught let's go gambling um no i never
played any like gambling games before like gambling card
games before so i actually don't know how to play except for
what was it the only the only card game gambling card game
that i know is 21.
i don't know the actual name for it wait where he's like hit
me you know hit me that's the only that's the only card game
i know it's just don't get to 21.
that's it is that blackjack that's the only card game I know
because it's just don't get to 21 also I really want to show
you guys this but there's apparently new production photos
of the uh of the new Mandalorian show and um so apparently
uh what's his name uh Jabba the Hut son is in it and you you
know you sort of have uh oh you have to get sorry you have
to get as close to 21 as possible yeah sorry but not over
see I told you I'm not very good at gambling with card
games.
Sorry, a movie.
And then you're going to think, oh, Jabba the Hutt's son.
You know, he looked a lot similar.
And then this man has a fucking six-pack.
Like, yeah, he's simply roared it up.
He has...
This Jabba the Hunt side, it was not...
I literally thought this was AI.
I literally was like, this has to be fake, right?
Is that Discussing Fish?
Because it was Discussing Film that posted that tweet.
And I was like, that has to be the parody account.
Discussing Fish, right?
But no, it was the...
It's real.
He's shredded as hell.
I was not expecting Jabba the Hunt.
His name is Rada the Hunt now.
So Rada the Hunt.
He's riding up for sure.
so this is java's son uh rada um and i legitimately this was
the last image that i had of him when you sell me java the
hudson i don't think i would have imagined all of this i
like all of this seems really wrong um but maybe like you
know his dad dying was like the turning point for him you
You know, he was like, I can't be like my dad.
Like, his life changed after that.
So, anyway, let's go play Poker Night at the inventory,
guys.
Uh, all right.
There's like, surprisingly, the reviews, this game came out
yesterday.
I was very surprised about this.
This game came out yesterday and it already has almost 2,000
reviews.
I was very surprised about that.
Like, and it's overwhelmingly positive, too.
Like, I was not expecting that.
Because it literally came out yesterday, too.
So, like, it was such a surprise.
I launched this game.
Yeah, it's old, but, like, I meant, like, the game came out
yesterday on Steam.
I know it's an old game, but that's what I mean.
Like, the game came out yesterday on Steam, and it already
has 2,000 reviews.
So I was very surprised.
Because, you know, there's, like, a lot of other games that
get re-get, get, like, released on steam that doesn't have
like um that doesn't have like that many reviews at the same
time it was delisted so oh it got it was delisted at first
or was it the same steam listing though i just thought it
was like really fast to have it go okay is this celebrity
poker dot exe i hope this is the right game that i just boot
up oh it is you know the the file name is called So I was so
confused.
I was like, I hope it's celebrity poker.
Oh, that's what.
Okay, that makes more sense.
I was going to say like 2,000 reviews in 24 hours is pretty
crazy.
I was just like, wow.
That's really fast for a game to get that many reviews.
It just got re-listed.
Then that makes sense.
That makes sense.
It was just the re-listing.
All right.
this loading time is pretty long
i'm a little concerned okay i'm turned down the volume
screws up the order of poker hats most likely i've never
played poker before i i am uh i am learning live uh and you
think you the super chat thank you thank you i don't know if
it's sound guys alive i'll turn it down a little bit i've
always wanted to try this apparently you get you get hats
you get like hats and stuff okay we'll do normal strong
language turn wait does that mean if you don't want to hear
swear i do i was just like yes i want strong language talk
to me Chewing the fat.
Okay, I want you to talk to me.
I want to hear all the conversations you're having.
Yeah, so you can grab, get like, TF2 items instead of film
green.
Motion blur off.
I'm like that.
I wish this was, like, always default off.
Fuck yeah, we want that shit.
Yap, my ears off.
All right.
Oh, sound.
Cool.
The guy who murdered Sound Guy is here.
All right, here we go.
yeah swear to your heart's content we're all murderers here
anyway except for me guys i'm the exception i'm the
exception all right we're here to get i it's crazy to see
penny arcade in this game too like do they still make comics
i don't even know are they still around
oh yeah yeah they brought you can still unlock the hats in
this game too so a lot of people are oh is that where the
poker another enthusiast i presume yeah how good it is to
see a fresh face here at the inventory i imagine you're here
for the card game with the fellow downstairs let me lead you
down there okay i see them
that's alive is like not a lot you know like the where their
game is sort of still alive or like their presence is still
sort of alive is heavy in response to an early draft of the
18th amendment through back channels it was learned that
this vile piece of legislation would not only outlaw
libations but games and amusements that could also threaten
the world-renowned determination and productivity of the
american workforce can you imagine games outlawed
nevertheless this how can this happen ever since just in
case those in charge get another b in their bonnet max is no
when was the last if you showed this bunny to a zoomer will
they be able to know who he is you killed because it's your
job not because you like it friends they give their super
chat As me.
Very well.
In concordance with the house rules of the inventory set
forth by Mr. Kent upon the club's founding.
Any congregation of five players around a no limit hold'em
table must play for the house stakes of $75.
Oh my, that's a lot of money.
This is not too much.
Of course, these stakes were set in 1910 and with inflation,
let's see.
Tonight's buy-in will then be $10,000.
Oh, that's a lot now.
okay how did all wait okay i can understand heavy how do all
the rest of you guys have ten thousand dollars i will
periodically raise the blinds may the best player win oh
yeah no you still get the items apparently all right in
poker players create hands of five cards poker is played for
money goods and sometimes services what kind of services
nexus home or dealt two cards and make hands using five
community cards dealt face up in the center oh my god okay
guys i think you guys might need a backseat beyond this uh
any poker players any uh poker dragoons in chat i'm already
a bit i'm already a bit confused
take thank you super chat thank you thank you um remember
dokey the best strategy is to go all every single hand thank
you super chat thank you thank you was created when the el
peso dealers union complained of restraint when dealing a
full five card hand after a lengthy strike from the by the
insufferable louts this stately variation was born use the
best five cards of the seven to create your hand the two
players to the to the left the deer post the blinds small
entities that all players much match to stay in the hand.
Your two cards are the basis of your hand.
They are known as your hold cards.
Playing with high pairs, high cards of the same suit are
cards of sequence is prudent play, although any two cards
have a chance of winning.
Now comes time to bet your hand.
If you haven't posted a blind, you can choose to match the
blind or raise the bet.
There is no limit to what you can bet.
During any betting round, you can bet all your chips and go
all in.
Look around you.
Are nearby women experiencing the vapors?
Are men clutching their billfuls like crimping scaly webs?
Yes, then you've probably gone all in.
After a round of bedding, the first three community cards
are placed face up in the center of the table.
At any time during the flop, you make your hand refrain from
chortles, smirks, or flatulence.
Another round of bedding occurs.
A fourth card is added to the community cards.
The final card is added to the community card.
After a particularly saucy night at the inventory, I
demanded a card to be added to the table and was asked to
leave my own game the final round of betting occurs when all
the betting is finished uh or players have gone all in each
player must show his or her cards and a winner is oh wait do
they have tails too okay that's that's cool that's
interesting so we gotta see if any of them's bluffing i
don't have a tail because i don't know what i'm doing
collect your winnings with dapper confidence or sure hand
elegance whichever you prefer If you don't know how to play,
they can never figure you out.
Oh, shit.
I just need a queen.
Can't be that bad.
I'm calling.
I call.
Wait, you guys can't see my cards.
Wait, I just realized.
Wait, okay.
Let's just, I think it's, I think it's left side.
Oh, shit.
No, I think it's left side dokey tab.
I just realized you can't even see what cards I'm holding.
There we go.
Alright.
Oh, shit.
J-Queen.
J-K-Queen.
Wait.
I just need a 10.
I call.
Wait.
What's check?
What is?
I need a 10.
I'm not getting any younger.
What's what's probably getting more dignified?
Wait.
What's what's check guys?
Free card?
Just need a 10 yet.
Alright, you stay.
Okay, awesome.
I'll call.
Alright.
Uh.
Oh, check means you don't bet?
Oh, okay.
I'll check.
I'm gonna call.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
maybe the fifth call card guys guys i'm gonna check check
check oh shit okay
i'm calling i'm raising i'm calling call lest you be called
a pansy fold no this this the last guide will be a and guys
guys the last card will be a 10 i can feel it oh oh oh wait
i have two fours there's no way they hired you haven't never
wait wait guys wait they might have worse yeah maybe they
have two threes sometimes i just black out when life reaches
a peak level of boredom oh a tiny okay bring it up a tiny
bit okay brought it up a tiny bit guys guys it's we guys you
know you're right i'll check the family is sam's favorite
norman lear comedy i think well i'm willing to wager this
much that it is okay 300 okay he's raising okay
I call it.
He's bluffing.
That's He's bluffing.
I'm calling a call There's no way Oh my god.
Come on.
Stop.
I'm gonna keep calling Five is the player has a pair of
fours.
Yeah Strong bad has two pair max wins the head.
Oh I can't promise I won't wave it around in front of you
forever reminding you of this it's okay I still have I can
make it back guys I can make it it's just the first game no
guys it's fine it's I it's just the first game guys oh my
god max is fucking it oh my god he can play for hours
it's okay I still have 2.9k strong bad has less money than
me guys it's okay I can still win this I call.
Can't wait to see me, a flippy floppy.
At least this is better than poker night at home stars.
Marzipan's always walking around all natural.
Ace and queen?
Like, look at that shit.
That's winning numbers.
What's no loser Candyland?
I don't know.
I should raise your right.
All in.
I don't even need to see the rest of the cards.
Raise.
I'll re-raise.
I'm calling.
Don't worry, I got...
Look at this.
Look at this, guys.
Watch this.
Lame.
What?
Watch this.
The next one is gonna...
Oh!
One pair!
A pair of fives.
Strong bad has two pair.
Oh.
has a pair of fives Tycho wins the hand Tycho wins the hand
I figured you weren't gonna like these cards guys I might
not be very I don't think I'm very I don't think I'm very
good at poker guys I has been eliminated from today what oh
just because it's my first time playing don't worry that was
just a prep that was just warm up guys it was just warm now
sorry i do not have this money i did but sasha has been very
good lately and i wanted to get her he wants she treats her
right guys i have no choice do what no heavy no i have no
choice to buy in with Oh, I can keep on.
It's beautiful.
I hope this is all right.
Oh, my God.
We have to win Sasha.
With it.
Whoever knocks him out, we'll receive his buy-in.
Oh, my God.
This is getting real.
This is serious.
We gotta be serious now.
Yeah.
I need to get the eye and curtain.
I'm gonna fall and then sit here.
I can do nothing.
together guys I'm not going anywhere okay we'll check
someone you don't want to give a bad check to Flint paper
fiscal disturbances make that man do horrible things I have
to win this oh checking we
got a raise I'm calling oh my god we got three kings we got
oh check disc okay three of cad we gotta keep okay let's
check oh wait two pairs and three wait that's winnable right
do we just go in do we just go all in am i going i'm raising
it all in Oh, Tycho, Tycho, you're stupid.
Ah!
Tycho has been eliminated from play.
Get out!
Get out of here!
I'm here for Sasha.
Full house, baby.
Full fucking house.
I told you.
that last game that last game was me role-playing i was
sandbagging on purpose
maybe i won't check oh so they so they have low expectations
about me guys
i'm gonna check i could turn it around these are false oh
this is wait 8, 7, 9.
I need a 10.
Two cards could be a 10.
I'm going to call.
Wait.
7, 8, 9, 10.
I need...
Okay.
The last one could be a J.
Guys.
The last one.
I could be a jack.
You don't know that
Wait, I have a pair of kings.
Wait, that works.
There's no way I'm gonna there's no way I get in here
Of course, I've got the best cards man.
That's what they call are you fucking kidding me Lana thank
you for the raising he has two pairs How is I supposed to
expect two pairs?
Okay.
That's fine.
Eden King, I'm in.
It's okay.
We just need...
Oh.
All right.
I check.
I check as well.
I want to check.
This is not much.
Oh.
I'm folding.
I'm going to fold.
This is, I don't have, this is not good.
I have ace.
Unless there's another ace.
Unless.
Oh, there's a potential for a streak, though.
Oh, okay, I'll fold.
I fold.
Check, check, check.
Check it out.
All right.
I check.
Yeah, I did.
It was not going to.
I was not going to win.
that take the money but next time you will not be so lucky
tiny man it's all right heavy folded as well thanks guys hey
uh boxing glove guy with a face like that have you ever
considered organized crime sam and i could come after you
and we try not to rough you up too bad i dabble in nefarious
activities like the time i stole the strong bad school game
for attractive people source code
That's why they don't exist no more.
Got the code over to my boys at BitElectrics.
Who turned the game into a triple platinum triple pixel
bestseller.
Whoa!
What game was that?
Wait, I want to play that game.
What is it Telltale gonna do?
Sue them?
They don't exist anymore, sort of.
Can't do nothing when we're defunct.
Oh, Ace and a three.
mean I'll check
wait I have two pairs I have to oh he mad okay I check oh my
god wait this is good wait I'm raising it okay I call two
pairs what is an ace too oh I'm calling two pairs I'm gonna
keep calling it okay ten doesn't matter to me i keep betting
nope oh i'll raise i'll keep raising there's no way there's
no way they have better cards than me no why would you fold
heavy i need your money i'm raising and not even caring i
keep raising i'm going to raise even higher you want fine i
would hate to play against me yeah you have that more than
me that's right keep going i ain't afraid It's not even
close to the card I want.
The player we...
Yes!
So easy.
I'm so good at gambling.
Next up.
One and two.
Okay.
Maybe I'll have another ace.
I fold.
I am in and ready to crash.
Oh, he's confident.
He's so confident.
You want a call?
Okay.
So see to The see to stop gasping Madra thank you.
Oh, he's angry.
He has a bad card Okay, I gotta get another pair.
I think I could do it.
I think I get another pair.
I'll check.
I'll check though just just to be sure $800
Fuck, I'll do 200.
I'll do 200 Nine fuck okay Okay, I do have nine.
Oh, I need Jack.
I need a Jack though and a King up.
I can't get any of that.
Maybe it'll be a two.
I think I'm folding.
I have a top pair, but they're gonna have two pairs.
What if they have two pairs, guys?
I'm checking.
I'll check.
You must have checked your coolness at the door.
let's see already i check yeah i bet that's almost all his
money
oh oh my god that's so much not worth it i'm floating no i'm
i'm not i'm not i'm not i'm not good heavy's losing more
money x wins the hand what was the card i didn't even see
what what was the card okay i got bluff what was his card i
don't even know his card i am out i don't know but what if
max max could have had a better card though he bluffed but
then max could have fucked me over.
Oh, this is such a terrible hand, though.
You know what?
I'm gonna call it.
Alright, I'm calling it.
I'll call that.
Okay, I just want to see the cards.
It's just $400.
I'm... Oh, well, one pair.
One pair.
I'm checking.
Oh, check.
All right, I'll be the one to put some money in.
Scared these.
Wait, I have three twos.
Three of a kind.
That's not bad.
I'm raising it.
Okay, I hope.
Come on, strong bad.
You're going to keep going?
Ah, easy.
Easy.
Man, should they use a super chat?
Thank you.
It is good.
There are many members.
Like a free pass to snuff out bad guys Or a waffle bar in
the commissary And full dental Wait, I think I'm
understanding I'm thinking of figuring out how to gamble,
guys I think I'm figuring it out How to play poker Oh my
god, wait, I can't get a flush I just need JN10 Call I'm
folding Already?
I'm calling Max, don't be a pussy He is full dental?
Of course, they're mercenaries oh wait I am raising oh
that's a lot oh I do show you're under can you beat me oh is
he bluffing he's doing the he's moving his necks there's a
chance though I
he's looking at me he's like do it pussy he's taunting me
he's like come on Do it, pussy.
You know you want to...
Oh, I can't outfold.
Outfold.
You don't even have any good cards.
Just raisin for no good reason.
Ooh, I could buy a new compi with that pot.
One with a half-core processor.
Hmm.
All of my chips.
They are coming for you.
Oh!
Wow.
Oh, the girls will go crazy for a huge bet like that.
I call.
Oh, what were the cards?
Huh?
No, no, no, heavy, you have to win this.
No!
No, no!
Strong bad has a pair of tens.
The heavy has a pair of tens.
Strong bad wins.
No!
Sasha!
The heavy has been eliminated from play.
Wait, can I win it from my can I win it from from strong
bad?
No, wait, I just gotta beat strong bad.
Okay.
Goodbye.
Oh, no, this is okay.
Okay.
I can still win it It's legally illegal.
I can still win it from strong bad.
Looks like someone else before.
Are you serious?
No, I can't even win it from strong bad.
Oh, and Max.
It's gone.
I didn't have cards.
Oh.
That's not fair.
I didn't even have the cards.
I didn't have.
I had nothing.
I can't even.
Okay, I call.
That's gamble for you.
Bet Sasha strong bad.
Bad him.
Oh.
Check.
I'm gonna check.
Let's do it.
That's why it's gambling.
One away.
What card do I need?
Nine, ten.
I need a J.
Oh.
Okay, play it still.
I'll check then.
Oh, reminds me of the time I played checkers with Superball
in the Oval Office with a board made of suspiciously
human-looking bone.
Okay, I...
Wait, how do I have a flush?
9, 10...
I don't have a J, though.
Wait.
Do I not understand poker?
What is...
Oh, I have five space!
I didn't even check the...
Oh, that's what flushes are.
with numbers.
Okay, wait, I'll just keep calling.
I'll call slow by slow.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what flushes are.
I'll raise.
I'll call.
Okay.
One, two, three, four, five.
Damn, right.
Get out of here.
A pair of nines.
Strong bad heads.
The player wins the hand.
That's not as good as the time I had a straight flush in a
full house in the same hand.
Yeah, let's think about a straight house.
How much money did I get?
How do you get a lot, though?
I thought if I kept raising it slow, they'll raise it.
Oh, my God.
He's just sitting there.
He's so sad.
He's like, how am I going to shoot the blue team now?
Oh, a pair.
I'm calling.
Call.
I'm raising.
I'll call.
That I'm right.
Get out of here.
Okay.
All in?
I only have a pair of fives, guys.
I'll call.
I have two pairs.
Wait, I have two pairs now.
There's no way.
I'll raise.
When I see that many chips in one place, I want to coat my
slick fur.
I want to raise it.
What?
The fort guard was supposed to make my hand undefeated
beatable.
That's right.
Get out of here!
Get your ass out of here!
Give me your money!
Oh yeah.
God.
Gambling's hard.
Gambling.
Yeah, I'm like, so hard.
Do it with a thigh.
Oh, yeah.
Let's do this.
If I realize how hard this is.
Yeah, this is a shit hat.
And I'll just check.
Yeah, I'm folding.
There's nothing here.
I'll fold.
You guys can win that.
Nice, guys.
The blinds are now 300.
Okay.
Blinds are now 300.
Yeah, I'm...
Yeah.
that's a I'm nothing oh ace and seven I call no I'll call
too I have enough I can put 300 down
okay I don't know if I could do anything with this but I
don't think I can do anything with this I have nothing like
I don't know I'll check I'll check that maybe I won't check
uh check I'll
check again let's do it all right
no this is pretty ass I have nothing I actually yeah I'll
fold it I'll fold I'm betting
a pair of Kings yeah okay makes heads a pair of Kings oh my
god wait I would have one anyway I wouldn't have done
anything here they're all bluffing I wouldn't have won
anyway though which were up your collective butt I don't
trust you one bit they all had nothing would I have won wait
why would have one I have a never-ending stack of aces
wherever you put your gun well you don't but you're come to
luck.
Yeah, we all had nothing.
Uh...
Oh, I was...
Wait, what does that mean?
Oh, I had an ace, so because my cards are not... Oh!
Oh, but he had an ace as well.
Oh, my God.
These guys were fucking with me.
Wait, I could have a flush here.
Okay.
Yeah, all of us were bluffing.
All right, I'll call.
I'm raising.
Raising in the sun.
Don't worry about your chippies.
Little chippies.
I don't like how...
I don't like how none of us can see the cards right now.
But I'll call.
All right.
One pair?
Two pairs?
I have two pairs.
Wait, this is where...
Okay, I call.
All in?
Okay.
I have the money to call.
Fuck it.
All in.
I'm all in as well.
Okay.
Ace?
Did that sound like I care?
Oh, he doesn't care.
He had nothing.
Oh my god, three pairs.
Let's go strong bad has two pair the player has two pair max
wins the what?
This reminds me of a story about a rabbit and his
ostentatious What?
How because he is strong bad has been eliminated from play.
I don't even know why He got saved by the ace.
Oh my god, I could have gotten that jaffa cake's problem
anyhow
it's because i have a seven are you fucking kidding me i had
a it's all right we eliminated strong bed he had a queen
okay where there is a chance that no one expects the
lagomorphic inquisition i ways
I didn't know it was three pair.
Man size is five.
Okay, I'm learning poker.
I'm still, I'm learning it as we go along.
I have one pair.
I don't know.
I can't get a flush, though.
Checking.
I'm checking, too.
We'll check.
Oh, this is nothing.
Can you check again?
I'm Betty.
Oh, what?
Max, why?
I only have This hand kind of sucks I don't know if he's
bluffing or not though
I'm folding You're just gonna fold?
But now I can't guilt you into overbearing bad cards By
putting on my cute rabbit face Max wins the head I don't
know, was that bluff?
Was that a bluff?
Look at my cards I don't know Oh my god Oh okay 10 and 2 i
call i raise he has no he's not oh he has no idea what to we
will never know you can never tell what he's doing he's just
he doesn't even know what he's doing he's just like me he's
just like me i'm at trap thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you because i don't know i'm learning time I've
ever played poker.
The cat mind gave the mindless.
Alright, I raise.
He still wants the raise?
Fuck, okay.
Call.
Oh, that...
I'm gonna bet.
9-10, Queen King.
Oh, I'm...
Maybe I can bluff him.
He's got two set.
There's no way.
I have a pair and then...
Maybe he has nothing too.
You're right.
Maybe he has nothing.
Max has a pair of jacks.
The player has a pair of twos.
Max wins the end.
The gravy chain rolls on.
It's okay, it's okay.
I'm giving him low expectations right now.
Guys, that's not nothing.
I'll check.
Spine tinkling check.
I'm checking.
Oh.
Oh, okay.
I feel like I should fold.
Oh, Ace of Nine is pretty...
Okay.
I mean...
I'll bet high.
There's no way he'll expect that.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm out.
Yes!
Fold it.
Nice.
4,000.
Okay, that's fine.
Alright, I bluffed him.
Okay.
There we go.
See, he's like...
He's at low expectation.
of me, you know?
What's the word where he doesn't think I have it in me?
Hold, raise, hold, raise!
You mess with the machine's head, Doki.
We believe in you.
You know, he has zero expectations on me and so he thinks I
don't know what I'm doing and jokes on him.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Raise!
I'll keep raising.
Okay.
Oh, check.
I'm checking as well.
Oh.
One more stay.
I call.
How long was I out?
I just black out when life reaches a peak level of boredom.
I just need one more.
I'll check that.
Oh.
Yeah, but I have nothing after that.
The pot is 14,000.
It's four times like these that I like to kick back and
ponder the intricacies of existence.
Like, why do my nipples exist?
I don't even use them that much anymore.
I'll check.
I would check those cards too.
Am I in your head?
Max has.
We are the kind.
The player has.
a pair of kings max wins the hand this reminds me of a story
about a rabbit and his ostentatious bank account i can
rebound i can read but i can beat the rabbit it's fine i'm
not dead yet guys i'm not i'm not out i have a lifeline
you'll drag my corpse
I fold this is not worth it this is not worth it this is not
worth it it's not worth it all right this is fine
see that stupid smiling face I can't check there's no check
I can only call or raise that smug ass rabbit what's in your
head I can't there's only call or raise What's in you what
are you thinking?
little man What are you I'm calling maybe?
raise raise I still can't check He's trying to take all my
money I call
Oh Oh Check.
Oh.
Check.
No!
There's no way.
He doesn't know what he's doing either.
So I'm all in to you.
I'm all in as well.
Max has a pair of aces.
The player.
Yes!
Does that sound like a pair?
That's right!
He had nothing!
He had nothing.
I'm gonna call.
Oh my god, he had nothing.
I called your bluff check.
It's just that easy, guys.
I told you, gambling is so...
End game!
End game, end game.
Wait, 9, 10?
Jay?
Wait, check.
Wait, I can't have a flush.
I can't have a flush.
I just need one more.
A call?
Mine.
No!
No.
I'll check.
Okay, I bet.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Okay, all in.
All in.
The player has a flush.
Oh, yes.
Those are the sorts of cards I'm supposed to have.
Yes.
Oh, my God.
All in.
Luck, lady.
Luck is on my side.
Let's fucking go.
Too fucking easy.
Check.
Holy shit.
Lady Luck answered my prayers.
Have you ever danced with a lagomorph in three inches of
water with an exposed electrical side?
The comeback is real.
Heart of the cards, baby.
Heart of the cards.
Lady Luck is smiling upon me.
No, I don't think I'm going to get hard flush.
There's no way.
I'll raise.
I call his death.
Oh, fuck.
Guys, these cards suck ass.
I might...
I'll check.
Oh!
Three pairs!
Wait, three pairs!
There's no way.
Alright.
I'll bet.
I'll call that.
I got three pairs.
Get out of here!
Oh, I should have raised.
I thought he would challenge me.
I thought he would fucking challenge me.
Oh, sorry, three of a kind.
That's sorry.
Oh, I thought he would fight back, but he didn't.
I didn't realize he was a fucking coward.
I thought we would be that do like a back and forth.
I'll check.
Okay, one pair.
I have one pair right now.
No, guys, it's 7-6, guys.
It's 7-6.
I'll tell you someone you don't want to give a bad check to.
Flint Paper.
Fiscal disturbances make that man do horrible things.
I'll check to.
What's the next card?
This shit, this is ass.
this is ass no I should fold this is these are ass cards I'm
folding max wins the hand yeah
but it's a shitty it's a shitty card though I don't have a
check though no there was no check I saw it there was no
more check let's see oh I
Oh, I bet.
Oh, I bet for me too.
I call.
Oh, I fucking...
I'm...
I'm all in.
This is...
I don't think so.
Oh, you coward.
You fucking coward.
All right.
I told you
I'll check I'll check what do we have here I know I was
thinking about luring him in but that was like maybe you
know because he's random you know he might be like oh we're
gonna play that type of game are we and then we'll just like
we I'm float folding yeah I'm folding this That's nothing.
S-fold.
Okay, I have a pair.
I call.
I would raise every time it's my turn, but that just seems
classless.
Excuse me, sir.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you.
I think the wrong artist is linked for the thumbnail.
I can't, art can't find.
Excuse me, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, is it?
Oh, my manager made the waiting room.
So he might have put it.
He might have forgot to change the credit.
Let me do that real quick.
Uh, oh yeah, that was from Pokopia.
Alright, I changed the credit.
You can check, only check if you're already put in the
highest blind.
Uh, Tate, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
I call.
Come on, show me what you got.
Okay, I check.
Uh.
Mmm.
I'll check.
Just to be sure.
I'm gonna check.
I'll check as well.
I don't...
Yeah.
I don't think...
Okay, I would have got...
That's two pairs.
I'm betting.
I'll bet a thousand one hundred.
There you go.
I'm slowly.
Yeah, sure.
I'll keep raising.
I'm gonna fold.
It's five.
Give me your...
I'll slowly milk that money out of your pocket, Max.
Slow and steady.
Oh, you had nothing, didn't you, little rabbit?
That's right.
I might not get Sasha, but I'm eating rabbit tonight.
I'll check.
I have nothing.
I have nothing for this.
I'll check.
I would check those cards too.
Am I in your head?
Ah,
this is ass.
These cards are ass.
I'm full.
That's nothing.
The lines are now 600, 1200.
600, 1200.
Okay.
He has a 1200 blind.
Thank God.
I could have a flush here.
I'll call.
call again oh never mind okay I bet never I have nothing oh
fuck I don't know if he has anything I can only call a raise
now I can't check mmm he
has a pair he must have a pair
you're right well this is great all that brain power I was
using playing cards can now be put towards imagining unique
ways for all of us to meet our slow I'm gonna force in the
fold I'm bluffing no I hope he calls I hope he calls oh fuck
I didn't think I didn't think he'd do it I...
I didn't think he'd do it.
I didn't think he'd fucking do it, guys.
He's bluffing, Doki.
He's...
But I have nothing, too!
I don't have anything!
Oh.
He's bluffing.
You have...
He's stupid.
You're on your right.
I'm staying in.
i call your bluff oh i think i saw no no he has a queen no
the player has two pair we shall be rewarded for our victory
oh my god okay it's okay i can i cannot salvage this I can
salvage this The one time he goes all in I'll call We might
have a good hand here Oh two pairs Two pairs, that's good
I'll check Checking I'll check Back the square one You know
what?
Oh, I raised Yeah, that's right, raised with me There's no
way I call I'll
Come on.
I'll bet, too.
I'll...
Come on, it's too big.
I don't even look
at my cards.
I'm still in.
I'm still in the game.
game I'm still in a
call I'll see that and raise you raise me all right all in
fuck it let's go he has to appear okay there has to be a
nine there has to be a nine in there are you fucking okay
there has to be a nine or a ten there has to be a nine or a
ten.
There has a nine or a ten.
That's all I need.
Max has two pair.
The player has a pair of twos.
Max wins the hand.
No!
Max wins the tournament.
Did you know poker is based on the he wins on a pair of
threes?
And he didn't know my uncontrollable gas is caused by my
15th serving A stupid ass rabbit.
It is stupid fucking rabbit.
It's fine.
It all went downhill when that one guy was like, he's
stupid.
It all ended.
And I was like, you're right.
He is stupid.
Sandwich, Sandwich.
I love you, Sandwich.
You can't listen to chat telling you to fluff.
You can't fluff one that has no thoughts.
Okay.
Damn it, my parlay.
Mal, thank you for the aqua soup.
Thank you.
Two quill archos with this girl.
There are only two brain cells at this table and they belong
to the mini-gun.
Lonnie, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I call.
Maybe it's good that James Bond went to Casino Royale
instead of Doki.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
There's a chance we're flush though.
There's a chance.
There's no more chances.
Check City, USA.
I'll check.
I'm gonna bet.
I'm folding this crap.
Too much tiny rays, tiny man.
And I was worried I was going to have a hand I could play.
What a flop.
It burns my eyes worse than when I dip my aviators in sodium
hydroxide.
Fine, Max is so rich right now.
have nothing.
I have nothing.
I'll check.
I'll... I fold.
I have nothing.
I actually have nothing.
The hemi wins the hand.
Best strategy when fighting heavy weapons, guys.
There's no more check.
I checked the last check.
Heavy weapons, guy.
It's okay.
It's fine.
We can... We can weed them out slow and steady.
yeah raising it up oh my god everybody's raising i call yeah
hold
oh come on don't you want full you're in you know what all
right oh that's nothing maybe i can bet i bet a little all
right maybe maybe i can bluff them as is conclusively.
It's me and heavy.
You know what?
I raise.
V-raise.
I raise, too!
Oh, shit!
You know what?
I raise as well!
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I didn't think... Oh, please tell me he has nothing.
Oh.
I It is your turn We wait You know what?
All right I raise I promise I can keep raising too It will
not last long I kill quick But not cleanly I'm sorry Giant
man is not afraid You're not afraid I Oh, fuck
Do it all in I Pull yes, yes, I pulled Yes,
okay, get faded now get blown.
Oh my god Oh my god, I plopped it till I make it I did it.
He's not afraid.
Well, let me show you something to be afraid of.
Tiggered.
Danger boy.
He thought I scared the AI.
That's looking right.
I check.
I'll check.
That's right.
It is possible.
Okay, wait, this is pretty good.
A pair of...
Wait, this is a good car.
I call.
Okay, I raise.
Oh, that's a lot.
I'm a pair of twos, though.
I'm honest with you.
You should call me.
Get out, I'm a pair of twos.
It's a pair of twos.
Yeah, but it's a pair.
Could be a five, though.
A pair is a pair.
All right, I'll fold.
Tycho wins the hand.
If y'all could just keep giving me the money, I'd be all
right with that.
Imagine if it's a third, too.
I wish I could see the cards after.
There's a chance for a flush, though.
Hey, Max, remember when you found that time machine and went
back to 1964 and met Mama Bosco?
out of curiosity did anything ever happen with that well sam
and i jumped through time and encountered a cow hybrid
version of bosco on a spaceship no i mean with mama bosco
yeah what did you yeah what did you do you guys get down to
anything oh i just need one more toward even i'll bet i'm
betting i'm betting you can tell me i just need one more i'm
so close Are you asking me if I ever stopped Mama Bosco?
Yeah, did you?
Oh, she must have been hot, right?
Aw, cowards, you fucking cowards.
It's all right, slow and steady drain them dry.
I'll call.
I actually like getting unplayable cards.
It gives me time to daydream of Busty women and all my
favorite damn, was Mama Bosco Busty?
But Max, you don't even like your matcha.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you.
He does have the ability to cloud one's judgment.
I'm raising.
Okay.
You know what?
I'll raise, too.
I'll raise.
I bet there's a flush down there.
Oh, fuck.
Okay.
I bet the full amount.
What?
the full amount down in front of me is the card beast of
your worst poker nightmare just something to consider wait
what is max into
we don't even know what they're lying I'm calling I'm
calling I still have the money
king and ace I have an ace and six
okay God damn it.
Okay, come on.
Come on.
No, wait, come on!
Come on!
Come on, spade!
Come on, lady luck!
No!
Wait, pair!
The heavy has ace high.
Tycho has ace high.
The player has a pair of sixes.
The player wins.
Yes!
Get out of here, Tycho!
Get the- look out of here lady luck lady luck oh my god the
one time he doesn't if only he had sasha i bluffed my way
out i am sent to my death i told you lady luck is looking
upon me right now has been eliminated from play the double
limit double kill the blinds are now 200 400.
All right.
Here we go.
The cowards.
The fold cowards.
Let it ride.
Aphelia, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You all might get it straight here.
I call.
I have enough money to do this.
I'll check.
Oh.
Calling.
I'll call.
Ah, fuck.
I'll check that.
I'll bet.
I'll fold.
I'll.
This is nothing.
Fight each other.
Alright, that's fine.
Oh my god, it's me and Max again.
It's me and Max again.
Two and ace.
Okay, okay, there's a flush chance.
Another flush.
I'm always dreaming about the flush.
I'm calling too.
I'm calling.
I'm checking actually.
one three of a kind three of a kind there's no way i bet
you're a bit of a beginner yes are you talking two more you
betcha you're as green as the bologna and sam's mini fridge
shut up stitch it's okay it just means you have to adopt a
wanton strategy of wild deception not the worst idea i have
a hoid get into their heads i'm betting i'm calling i'm
betting I'm raising I'm going I raise That's fucking right
Go all in, strong bad Go all in, that's fucking right
There's no way Strong bad has Two pair The player wins Yes
Yes Get out of here Get fucking Get fucking out of here
cheaters that's fucking right it's me and max again just
like the good old days just like the good old days i can't
read him there's nothing in there to read insta pair i call
i call check no one my arch nemesis i'm getting my running
back right now there's nothing in that head
I'm raising.
Sprinkling a few chips into the pot reminds me of feeding
mini sausages to the alligators that live in the Manhattan
sewer system.
I raise.
You know what?
I'll raise again.
All right.
I raise.
You know what?
I raise again, too.
Fine.
I can do it.
You know what?
Okay.
I bet.
Oh, fuck.
You just need to pair for J or an Ace.
I raise even higher.
I raise.
I'll keep raising too.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here, Max.
I can raise all night.
I can...
That's fucking right.
The raise...
raise these stupid I told you guys I could raise all night
baby when you left max you were put the learner now you are
the master sir thank you for the super chat this was ass I'm
folding you'd have this that's nothing it's fine I gave him
just he just has he's just 900 dollars oh i'm college all in
i'll buy it all in all right what do you have i literally
have the god head what please no diamond please no diamond
please no diamond please no diamond please no no no no no No
diamond, no diamond.
No, they can't do this to me.
Meg says a straight.
The blue has a straight wax rings to hand.
I don't even look at my cards.
The blind runner, 306.
Don't swim.
Why?
What?
a straight here's a straight that's great from this ai max
is not real he's not i'm all in he had the highest rate by
one oh my god he's literally going he's like he's like
scratching it off one by one little by little scratching the
money away from me okay a pair of kings I'm a pair of kings.
It just has to be a queen.
No ace, no ace, no ace, no ace, no ace.
Oh.
Frustration!
The player.
Yes!
A pair of kings.
Meg says a pair of ninos.
The player wins the head.
There, get out of here, Max.
Get out of here.
The tournament.
Whoa.
What happened?
That's fucking right.
Revenge!
I have only improved my character arc is complete I am the
bluff master get out of here you stupid rabbit you might
have one brain cell but I have zero Oh, I got a new table?
Wait, how do I...
How do I change the table?
I'm gonna get him talk more if you want.
The raise off.
Wait, how do I change the table, guys?
You may have one, but I have three.
Oh, start a new game and then hit escape.
Okay.
Oh, there we go.
Oh, is that it?
Okay.
Let's grab that.
Wait, what the fuck?
Alright, take me to the max place.
Oh, do I have to click it?
Oh, whoops.
Yeah, I want this.
I'm ready.
I'm back.
You thought you saw the last of me?
You thought I would...
You thought I was just gonna take the winnings and dip?
No.
I'm back to play some more, baby.
You can't...
You can't get...
You gotta chase me away.
Okay, that's nothing.
No way.
I'll fold.
There's nothing here.
I fold.
That's right.
Falling!
These are a check.
I'm now a regular to your little poker night.
Jesus Christ.
Okay, yeah, there's no way.
I had nothing.
These chiefs want blood.
Who will give it to them?
And I'm out.
The heavy wins the hand.
I win?
I don't even remember cards.
Oh, he was bluffing.
Sorry, he gets like $5.
Nothing for him.
There's nothing for us.
Okay.
You know what?
Nice.
I'm doing it.
69?
Nice.
That's...
I will play.
Raise.
That's a nice hat.
Exactly.
These are cards of a winner.
I am going to play this one.
And me and Tycho.
I am not betting but I do not quit you know what checking
this oh you guys are checking I'm betting raising I'm out me
and heavy I'll raise here about the inventory oh Sam heard
about it when we were on a case out west and I'll loiter
just about anywhere that will pour me a drink with no
questions asked my engineering brought me one night.
The only good thing I got out of those telltales was a
recommendation for a decent hangout.
Oh, damn.
I raised.
You can have it.
That's right.
I knew you had nothing.
I had nothing too.
Wow, loved you, mercenary man.
I'm in like Florence Nightingale.
I'm totally in this hand.
Total, man.
I will fold.
I'm nothing.
I'm up.
I'll fold.
This is nothing.
I don't know, though.
I'm the ultimate bluffer.
I've got five on it.
And by five, I swear to guys, I was a flush.
I swear to guys.
There's no way.
I check.
I'm outy 5,000.
That's 5.
They're playing for pennies right now.
This ain't nothing.
These are pennies.
Oh, I'm going in.
These are a good one.
Hey, Max, give me the skinny on your pockets.
Excuse me.
use me you know where you keep all that stuff that's like
hollywood magic right yeah but that was a nickname of mine
in college really no i never went to college oh one more one
more i'll check i'll check i'm gonna check
oh okay one more
That's it.
You know what?
I'm raising it.
Oh, man, you want to fold?
That card sucks pretty bad.
Yes!
Alright.
Nice.
There you go.
I didn't trust it.
I wanted to see if I could bluff my way out of here.
Oh.
Who knew cards were capable of sodomy?
What?
how no I think I think I could have a pair here I think I
could get a pair I'm so good at lying guys first time too
I'm a natural okay a pair I got a pair I might be like a
prodigy in poker you know what you guys are gonna check I'm
going in Hold And Yeah, that's what I call it I raise like
flag of motherland over a bloody battle You have woman Not
with me No But I have woman She is pretty Yeah, cute glasses
Red hair She has the red hair No, no, no, heavy She is not
on the other team You don't have to kill her No, but I love
the red hair well you can't have her either he's like what
do you mean i can't have it mother russia sharing is caring
another race yours is mine that pot is like half the gross
domestic product of strong barrier and our chief export
potash what was that tiny chips you all want to fight with
me This is best idea.
All in?
You would fight me?
It is not advisable.
But no one said.
I was smart.
I raised.
I'm full of this crap.
Okay.
I lost.
You want eight?
No!
Yes!
The heavy has three of a kind.
The player has a pair of eights.
I was like, maybe I'll have an eight.
Are you kidding me?
The heavy wins the hand.
It's okay.
I sub 9,000.
I can bounce back.
He can lose all that money in one play.
You can lose it all.
It's alright.
Nine and king.
You know what?
I'll call.
Seven, seven, seven.
Goddamn sevens.
Let's make game little more interesting.
Everyone is calling?
I call.
I think we have a chance with the cards.
I believe in the heart of the cards, guys.
ah fuck okay okay I check as well I'm good I check good
check what would gene shall it do check oh fuck okay I am
folding okay I raise
We could have a queen.
We can.
We have a chance.
I'll raise.
I don't think so.
Come on, don't you want to fall?
Come on, tight show fall.
You'll re-raise?
You know what?
I'll raise you to your re-raise.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
Never back down.
I'll never what I never back down from a race For the book
learning type Sam and I pinch their gym teacher in a black
market jockstrap ring in the 80s I'd be surprised if any
student didn't remember a dog choking out a large man with a
unibrow The bluff master wins again I call I mean never
surrender
okay can i just tap one of these and be done with it all in
all in i'll call oh yeah he has six hundred dollars i forgot
it's just like all in and i forgot he only has six hundred
dollars
i check this oh yeah i'm pretty sure they have bad cards i
bet i hate to call without the This may be bad.
Yeah.
Eight.
Okay.
I check.
I have nothing.
You got nothing.
I got nothing out of there.
Wait, seven, eight, nine, ten.
Jay, wait.
Wait, I have a straight flush.
That's the big shot at the count.
I'll bet.
That card ruined my day like a bad rash between my ears i'll
try to fold this is not much i'll slowly i'm just gonna
slowly check come on heavy keep betting now yeah yes yes has
a street how would you have a bitch the heavy has a straight
huh haiku has a street what I will take my half, but next
time I want it all Are you fucking kidding me?
This reminds me of a card This reminds me of a card Paper
beat the snot out of that poker instructor Arnie Flop Shark
It was a total scammer This someone brought an extra card
For money after cheating Someone brought an extra try
Someone's cheating and it ain't me this time Someone's
cheating Someone hit a card up some sleeves There is no way
That's actually crazy
Three straights.
The odds of that are astronomically...
There's no way.
He has them.
Check his pockets.
Check his PC.
Someone check his PC right now.
He has to be hacking.
Whatever I choose is going to be awesome.
I will play.
I call
Take his sweater off Make it play shirtless Okay, I have a
pair Okay, I check I'll check, I just have a pair Make it
interesting, shall we?
Like playing Russian roulette with a crossbow Trying to
raise me off the pot Because you think I have the wheel Or
the tire Or the Guatemalan tricycle I call raise can tiny
baby arms lift this many chips i'll call that oh my god
we're all calling i call you know what wait is it that type
of poker don't say ostentatious you are going to need much
bigger bed what the other than homestar runner.com do you
have any other favorite websites max for laying and wait for
criminals and general narrative wells around the city if
that's what you're asking i said do you have any favorite
websites yeah max they're gonna cost me 50 bucks when i'm on
the internet i can't stay away from www.teltailgames.com
does that even still exist wait okay telltale games smash
store does that even exist anymore
oh my god it's still around i didn't even think oh my god
hashtag ad i call
oh okay i check i am betting
ma 'am the ad worked yeah i fell for it again i call i check
wow what a move i am dead heavy is still going at it oh
i'm folding i can't bluff this i actually have nothing The
heavy has a pair of fives Tycho has a straight.
Yeah, okay.
Thank god.
Yeah, a fucking straight
Really two there's no way there's no way this guy man.
There's no way this guy is hiding cards This guy is hiding
fucking cards.
Am I right?
He has fucking cards up his sleeves fucking straight.
Oh my god, Max is out.
Oh my god.
The evil's been defeated.
Oh thank god.
Raid boss down.
So crazy that just got back into the game and then see it
coming back and you're playing it.
How familiar are you with poker in these characters?
Sketch.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I actually learned poker just now.
Wait, we were learning poker as we went.
This is the first time I've ever played poker.
I am out.
I don't think so.
Alright, I'm being strong.
Let's bet.
Let's keep going in.
I don't even know what I...
We don't even know what we have.
We're just winging it.
Pear Kings.
Oh, he has a queen, though.
And I don't...
I don't.
Oh, come on.
He has a queen.
And I don't.
No!
The player has a pair of kings.
Strongbad has a pair of kings.
No.
Do you even know how to play?
Strongbad wins the head.
I did it.
My heart of the cards.
They're taking a vacation.
You carry tiny, heavy.
Oh, you know, I've got bazooka, grappling gun, glue gun, my
special gun.
But I know tight choke and heavy.
Queen is seven.
We might have a flush here.
I'll call it.
Check.
Yeah, but I had a seven.
And he had a queen.
Okay, a pair of sevens.
I can call your bet and buy sandwich.
Queen.
Queen seven.
I'm going for it.
Sorry, two pairs, technically.
These are check.
Check.
All right.
I checked.
Oh, I bet.
Two pairs.
I raise.
Look, I'm sure that card made somebody's hand awesome, like
in Chinese, but I'm playing in English.
Are you ready?
Chokes on you.
I'm Chinese!
The player has two pair.
That's the heavy.
The heavy has two pair.
The heavy wins the game.
Are you fucking?
These cards make your cards look like you have tiny babies.
Oh, it's okay.
I'm still in the game.
I can win it back.
I'm still in.
Yeah, those are just baby money.
Baby numbers.
He's playing for, like, children.
I'm doing the lawn game.
I'll check as well, gentlemen.
I'm doing a lawn game.
Okay, one pair.
You know what?
I raise I raise I can call your bed and by Sandwich I'll
call
Come on I do not know I am not betting But I do not quit Oh
yeah, are you folding Oh, you guys are checking you fucking
cowards How about you throw in some more money In that pot
Oh Oh Yeah, all in call this baby bed I'm calling oh shit.
Okay, I'm that's not okay.
I'm a little afraid now.
I check Check this shit out Please I swear I swear to God if
you get What I swear I think it's a straight.
I swear to fucking God Are you?
The heavy has a pair of tens.
The player has your pair.
Tycho wins the hand.
See, I actually know how to play this game.
I do not think he's here legit.
I...
No!
What's next for you?
Curl up with an adventure game, perhaps?
Or are you just headed straight to a brothel?
No!
There's no way I there's no way he must he he sneaks some
cards in guys He sneaks like there's no way tight chill
there's no way that man has been having Cards after cards
after someone has to check his PC this guy is not legit He
is cheating I could see it.
I don't know how but I know he's cheating.
I swear to God.
I
There's no way $10,000
Taito!
There's no way!
Taito had two straits in a row and then coincidentally all
his pairs are just higher than my pair!
I assume you're talking to me.
You know it?
What sort of chintzy setup do you have at home?
He sneaked the entire deck of cards under his pocket.
Someone strip him!
Yeah, yeah, I hate you whatever.
I've got like a 500cc Supercore Compe!
Yeah, I'm folding.
There's nothing here.
The bells and whistles.
Tycho wins the hand.
Of course he does.
I don't even want to know.
I knew he was going to win it.
I don't want to see him win that shit.
I guess cheating is cool.
You want to make sure I don't win every hand by giving me
crap cards every time?
I will fall.
I'll call that.
Yeah, this is why no one...
This is why...
This is why you just do conventions now.
No one's reading your comics no more So now you're out here
gambling To chase the high You lost
Wow Are you familiar with Parapataya?
Well it has to do with getting hurt By a reversal of fortune
Yeah and I lost my life savings Whoa Low glow
You fell off, so now you're here with us.
Please, it's supposed to be a 10K.
Why are you being 10K friendly?
I fold.
I call.
I can't stand to be left out.
Check, check, check, get out.
All right.
Oh.
Uh, I check.
Oh, check.
I bet.
I raise.
Just a friendly, casual race.
I raise again.
I would hate to play against me.
Oh, I'll raise.
Oh, fuck.
I think I thought you would call my blood.
You're out.
Call it.
Fold.
I'm inside your head.
Yo, you're right.
Yeah, you're inside my head.
All in.
Wow.
Oh, I could buy a new copy with that pot.
One with a half-core processor.
I call.
That'd be neat.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Okay, I didn't think he...
Oh, he has an ace.
Oh.
He has two fairs.
He got me.
Strong bad heads.
Oh.
The pair has.
A pair of sevens.
Strong bad wins the hand.
All I gots is this.
Winning head.
in my head.
He got in my head.
God.
The player has been eliminated from I can't help it.
I'd hear like a real Ouch, man.
He baited me.
He was like, oh, you're not gonna do it, alright?
You're not gonna do it.
You're too much of a pussy.
You're too much of a pussy to raise it.
I was like, I ain't no pussy.
He read me.
He read me like a book.
The book only had one page.
It was pretty easy I'm folding This has nothing I played
like a fiddle You guys unionized Molly thank you for the
super chat thank you Thank you Grompo thank you for the
super chat Thank you You lose a measly 10 grand And all of a
sudden you're the saltiest gambler Around shaped by it Thank
you for the super chat thank you Thank you My book was one
one flashcard
I want to play this when the game first when it came out and
all the characters were relevant and recognizable I will now
crawl into my grave night show thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you I'm surprised they're unionized that
must have been redcon in the comics right red and blue does
not seem like the guys who would give them a you would let
them have a union what I did to deserve these cards perhaps
calling that lady a megatwatt yesterday has had some karmic
impact call show me what you got
okay you know i'll check you could potentially shall we
maybe i'll call so that's a raise then sure raise and then
sir I raise.
I'll raise.
I'll call your bluff.
All right, Max, you and me.
Remember my latent psychic powers?
You and me, Max.
Oh, not that I've been using them.
I'm gonna pull.
That's fucking right.
That's, I'm nothing to lose now.
They know.
They know I have nothing to lose.
They're playing against crazy now.
There's nothing in my head.
I just play with, I go with the bobs.
I just go with what feels right.
Right.
I'm unpredictable.
These cards make me want to rip off men's arms.
I'm just going to put this out there.
Strong bad.
Just grab an arm and start pulling.
Good luck trying to separate me from these guns.
Let's do this.
Okay.
Check.
Is lame.
Unless you are check, which I would find amusing.
I'm the wild card.
You know what?
You're going to check?
I bet.
Oh, you're going to raise?
I don't think so.
Foldsville.
Oh, oh, it's me and Max.
You have to call because you know what nefarious things I'll
find to do with the money if you fold.
Hey, that's not a real bet.
That's not a real bet.
I'll show you a real bet.
I see that many chips in one place.
I want to coat my slick fur and cooking grease and roll.
Roll around in them.
I'm gonna call.
Oh, all in?
Let's go, Max.
You and me, let's tango.
Come on.
Okay.
Lame.
Wait, yes.
Three.
Three pairs.
Oh, shit.
I can't have three players.
Max has two pair.
Yes!
My pair is better.
Eliminated from play.
Get out of here.
Get the fuck out of here.
You always lose to Max?
Jokes on you.
He always gets knocked out by me.
I've analyzed him ever since the first time I've lost to
him.
I know what he, what, he plays just like me.
But I know myself better than him.
I know what he's thinking and he's not thinking anything.
I, so no loot then.
Oh, you mean hot.
Yeah, risk it all to win it all.
I get these.
They are the best.
Alright, let's go.
I'm max farming.
I'm farming the shit out of him.
Coal.
Nope.
Yeah, that guy's cheating.
There's no way Tycho's playing legit.
I'll call.
I want to know what it's in the cards.
I'm folding.
There's nothing there.
check
Tiny bit the size of the tiny heavy ever since tito kept
getting eliminated the first hour He's been cheating ever
since so funny.
I don't know how but I know I know he's doing it I fall
Strong bad wins the hand wow what losers you all are I knew
it there was no Strong and bad.
I had a straight?
I didn't even...
No, I'm a wrestler man.
Ressle man.
I...
Not like Iron Sheik.
No, not like the Iron Sheik.
You know, this time, this time.
He's a lure.
Octapu.
I didn't know I was going to get a straight.
We don't know it's gambling.
Oh.
Two, three, four.
Oh, he has a shit.
Do you think his cards are shit, guys?
This is not much.
Okay, four drinks.
I raise.
I can call your bet and buy sandwich.
I'll fall.
That's right, heavy.
You and me?
Not much.
Not much?
I am not betting, but I do not quit.
I'll bet.
Call this baby bet.
Oh, fuck, okay.
I bet.
I bet too.
I will not let you get away without showing big man cards.
I'll keep going.
Two pair.
Yes, yeah.
The heavy has a pair of sevens.
Get out of here.
I wasn't bluffing.
I knew I had it.
There we go.
400 i got two pairs and he had nothing i called his bluff by
out bluffing him or i raise let's do this i am going to play
this one calling from baby dokey to poker prodigy
all right one pair i bet i raise i'm going to raise you some
more That flop has saved me some money with which I will use
to pay a sure-handed man to tear my hair out in bloody
clumps.
Mine.
I raise.
Okay, I call.
Oh, fuck.
He's going all in.
I don't know.
That's...
I feel like he has something.
I can't check.
I can only call and raise this time.
I call.
I check.
Not so much fun.
All in!
Oh my god, they're all in.
Call.
Oh!
He has a pair of kings!
Come on, not...
Oh!
The heavy has a pair of kings the player has a pair of
threes A pair of jacks the heavy wins the hand.
It's okay strong bads out though strong bads out It's okay
guys.
I knew it.
I had a feeling heavy had something, but we got strong bad
out Wait strong bad won the side pot.
Are you kidding me?
He won the side pot.
God damn it.
What are you?
Have we been over there?
I know your head is the size of a grapefruit, but come on.
He's still in!
You are not scout.
Maybe very tricky blue spy.
Maybe new class.
I can use a keyboard to sabotage your team, steal your
intelligence, and mail order your sister to my goddamn
doorstep all in an afternoon.
What the fuck?
I'm a new class.
I have a technical prowess beyond your wildest imagination.
He feels such like a Reddit guy.
The 10th class?
One, two, three, four.
Okay, wait.
He's free.
I need a five.
Check disc.
The way he talks, it feels like a Reddit mod.
Like the guy who made a video who was like, I should be
paid, like, where he was like, Are you serious?
I relied on the...
Oh, my God.
Up front that I've got your ass kicked preemptively.
I'm folding.
There's nothing here.
I don't need...
Yeah, I'm folding.
There's nothing here for me.
It's yours.
I don't trust Tycho.
Tycho.
He has something under...
Like, he has...
I don't trust him.
He has cards underneath his sleeves.
So I'm going to fuck with that.
If he puts all in, he has a fucking straight flush or some
shit.
Raise.
Call.
Oh, I could get a flush here.
Or straight.
These cards is broke.
Yeah, he sounds like that live stream fails mod that made a
fucking video.
I don't know if you guys seen it.
Two, three, four.
Okay.
I check this.
I bet.
I call it's not terrible
I just need a five I just need a five I just need a five
Wait why is Max just Oh wait not Max I was like that was
like Okay strong but okay I call Interesting
Yes!
Oh my god I should have I should have Okay
I bet.
Come on, Tycho.
I fold.
Ah!
It was so close.
It was...
Oh, I wanted him to bet more.
It's fine.
I'm slowly chipping away his money right now.
I'll call.
Just...
Heavy's being too much of a pussy.
These are check.
Okay.
Six, seven...
Boy?
I can call your bet and by send, bitch.
This is good soldier.
This one is good doctor.
You are demolition man.
Me?
Are you naming your chips?
Oh, no, it's chips.
They all fight like good friends.
Oh, that's sweet.
I feel like we should fold.
Unless... If we can get an 8.
And a 10.
I'm folding.
Yeah, no, this is... I'll let you.
them eliminate strong bad without me yeah i knew it yeah i
didn't have anything
oh my god
really oh a pair of queens the heavy has i could i oh it's
okay he knocked out strong bad he knocked out strong bad for
me Bro, are you serious?
A J.
All right.
I'm blowing this pop stinkle stand.
Oh.
I could have won.
But it wouldn't have been a lot of money anyway.
If you didn't have much left.
Where is Max?
Oh, there he is.
He was like, oh.
I will play.
I'll call that.
That means you should never fold.
You're right.
The lesson I learned is to never back down.
All right, I'm backing down.
I'll bet.
There's nothing here.
I raised.
I'm calling.
There was nothing I could do.
Okay, MVP knocked out Tycho.
There's nothing.
Oh, goodbye, Tycho.
Tycho has a pair of seven.
I always say tight joe.
Get out of here.
You must fight with weapons.
The heavy wins the hand.
Well, wrench can be a weapon.
Okay, it's a 1v1.
Me versus heavy.
Heavy.
If anyone's got cab fare, that'd be much appreciated.
Heavy supremacy.
Heavy's doing the heavy lifting.
I got Max up.
To be fair, Max is like all of these guys.
Heavy got heavy and heavy got strong bad Tycho.
I got maxed out.
You know what?
What are you gonna do?
I'll call.
I am raising.
You're raising?
You know what?
I'll call.
Oh, this is good.
This is a good one.
I'll raise two.
I'm a pair.
No.
That's right.
Get out of here.
Folded like a piece of paper.
I am in.
I'm ready to crush baby man.
Oh yeah?
I'm ready to raise it.
I raise.
Oh yeah?
Me too.
In.
Oh yeah?
All right.
I bet.
Come on.
Yeah, come on.
Yeah, tiny bet did you find chips in your diaper I call you
call
Oh, yeah, I bet you can have the point that's right get out
of here Pussy That's fucking right
I raise I'm ready to crush baby men all right I check okay I
bet I call this baby bed I'll need a check ah shit okay
check um okay maybe I do need a check I bet I bet too I
raise raise Oh shit.
I promise.
If you fight me, it will not last long.
I kill quick, but not cleanly.
I'm sorry.
I raise.
Oh!
Yes!
That's right.
Your threats ain't no match for me.
I ain't afraid of nothing.
Unless you're ghosts.
Unless you're ghost.
And maybe I'll be afraid.
Okay.
I raise.
I'm going to play this one.
I didn't even see what cards I had.
I was just like, fuck it.
Let's go.
I bet all of it.
All of it?
Uh.
I'll call.
I'm not afraid.
What do you have?
Oh, he's relying on the five there's no five no oh okay okay
I have nothing to no he has a pair come on chase chase chase
no what is this the player has two pair the heavy has two
pair the player I win I win I'm queen oh I win it's the
tournament you are strong like oh my god like dirty spy look
at that I win.
I won.
I had the queen.
That's right.
I, the trod dart, too.
Next deck in one win.
Oh my god.
Come on, Heavy.
I need you to bet your gun.
Come on.
That's it.
Wait.
Oh.
New game.
come on heavy show me that gun perhaps our newcomer would
like to set the stakes for tonight's game come on heavy here
you go some check i have to die heavy come on we gotta
re-roll tonight's stakes are made that
you keep having money very well in concordance with the
house at one time i lost sasha i have this no you don't no
you don't it's like a shiny hunt i'm shiny honey right now
reset reset count
okay some change i have well this is embarrassing i
generally walk around What does he have?
Which to buy into backroom card games, but I'm a little
light this evening.
Anyway, I think this should even it up.
Oh my god, we got a shiny.
A watch!
Let's go!
That's a Rolex.
The game will be no limit.
We're Sasha hunting.
I will periodically raise the blinds.
May the best player win.
All right.
We got his watch.
We gotta kill him.
And ready to crush baby men A fold No, I'll call Oh, I raise
It's not blood, it's just red paint, guys Strong cards would
be nice Don't worry about your chippies I'll call A little
chippies Alright, I raise Oh my god already, a thousand I
call I'll call
oh oh i bet oh i'm definitely betting i'm raising so much
money you're not the only one who can spread the moostar oh
my god okay i sell money i raised too responsibility that
comes along with fiscal capabilities i call where do you
think i am that tightwad king of town all right i'm gonna
bet i'm doing it oh come on guys guys the watch is right
here guys the watch is right here am i really gonna lose the
watch am i really just to let it run you damn right i will
No!
A straight has a pair of aces.
Strong Bad has a straight.
The player has a pair of aces.
Strong Bad wins the hand.
Of course I've got the best cards, man.
That's what they call me.
Got the best cards, man.
A straight has been eliminated from play.
I'll be at the bar.
A straight in the first first hand in the first fucking hand
got me the first what are the odds I just want it just want
my watch there's no way everyone has money I just want one
item I just want one the item okay cash cash oh wait okay
what did he get a briefcase full of cash in these bats on
account of my ample hind bosom but i do have these cool cool
fainty shady dangerous glasses they're worth like five ten
thousand dollars from from a million dollar gun to a a
million A million dollar watch and then the Timu sunglasses,
the Timu shades.
The...
The game will be no limit, Texas Hold'em.
The dead.
Stud or Albuquerque high low.
I will periodically raise the blinds.
May the best player win.
Oh, you're right, you're right.
You're so right, guys.
I almost forgot.
Wait, where is it?
Oh my god, wait, give me a sec.
I forgot something very important.
Now that I'm getting better at poker.
Now that I'm getting better at poker, guys.
Where is it?
Now I'm a real poker master.
Now...
Can't read my eyes now.
Can't read my tail.
Yeah, I'm out.
That's right.
Oh, they saw the glasses.
I am called Okay, we can't see if I'm bluffing now Now we're
gaming I am betting You see the cards in my reflection I
call out of here I raise Can tiny baby arms lift Oh my god
And I was worried I was going to have a hand I could play I
call Two pairs all right, I check I'll check to there don't
want to hurt yourself
It won't kill you to call I'll call I'll call the heavy has
two pair the player has two pair the player with yes, yes
buy one buy one that's right the aviators they're working
they're already working guys easiest play of my lives i'll
call that advisor buff
i'm calling i'll play you know what i'll raise it i'll raise
it i need to get rid of strong bad these are a good words
Oh fuck their spades.
What would Gabe do?
No, best leave the pants on.
That's nothing.
I'm folding.
There's nothing there.
Everyone's cards.
Yeah, I was like, five black cards.
And I was like, oh, it's their spades knocking over.
Yeah, we fold.
A pittance.
Ah, man.
Man, I fold.
These are good ones, too.
It doesn't matter.
I had nothing, see?
I'm good.
I'll bet.
I'm folding these.
It's fine.
Strong bad means the head.
Nothing like making a buck to easy one.
If it's just me, we just gotta make...
We gotta have one V1 with Strong bad.
I guarantee it.
Trying to get us to play no loser Candyland.
no loser candy land i don't know loser all right two three i
could have a straight here i call you know what i raise
these cards are weak like blue baby team can i just tap one
of these and be done with it i'm calling i raised i'm in
like florence nightingale i'll call calling all right show
me the cards Come on, come on, come on.
Oh, one, two, three.
I'll bet.
Hey, I call.
Well, calling.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
I don't think so.
All right, we got him out.
Ah, this is nothing.
I make a check it.
I check.
Let's do it.
Yeah, I'm...
Oh, yeah, that's nothing.
I full of...
I'll bet a small amount.
I'm nothing.
So your amateurs don't wet yourselves.
But dumb.
Oh, I race.
Yeah, that...
Oh, let them fight each other.
Okay.
Okay, all right.
All right.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Max, no.
Okay, dice.
All right, that's good.
That's good.
I'm gonna keep on winning.
Same type deal.
That means Trombat's not more likely not to die.
we need him to stay in the game hey max remember when you
found that time machine i need him to stay in the game oh
wait mama bosco yeah out of curiosity did anything yeah we
never we never figured it out if anything happened well sam
and i jumped through time and encountered a cow hybrid
version of bosco on a spaceship you know i mean with mama
bosco between you and her uh you know you guys get down to
anything toward i still have nothing maybe well sam was in
the time machine you can tell me i'll check i can still
check in the vault are you asking me if i ever stopped mama
basco paranoid thank you super chat thank you thank you i've
been i've been oh a pair
i have two pairs i raise i'll call i have two pairs The
player has two pair.
Yeah, Max.
Max has two pair.
The player wins.
Yes!
Yes, Jay!
Jay!
There we go.
Get out of here, Max.
Oh, nice.
See, guys, ever since the first time he fucked me up, I know
how he plays now.
I figure it out.
I've analyzed his playstyle, which was no playstyle.
I'm raising
I don't think so This is not a baby move What are you hiding
over there I will call Okay I'll raise Wait what's the one
where I bet all of my stupidly large pile of chips That's
all in Yeah that I want to do that I am folding What the
fuck what do you have I call!
We don't even know what cards we have!
Let's do this!
Let's ride, bunny!
Let it ride!
Oh no.
Oh no, come on, come on.
I need another pair.
Come on, give me another pair.
Give me an 8.
Come on.
Come on, I need an 8.
I need an 8.
No!
The player has a strange Oh, yes!
Oh, yes!
No!
I can't promise I won't wave it around in front of you
forever reminding you of this moment.
No!
The blinds are now 200, 400.
Oh, it's so close.
It's okay, I'll raise.
Hi, you straight.
How does he always have a street?
He was on life support and now he's back.
We both didn't even look at any of the cards and we both
went all in.
Isn't that crazy?
That's nothing.
I'll call.
All right, big pretense killer man.
Tell me the most awesome story you have with of super cool
senseless violence it is bad but i assume they would fold
but they didn't i was at camp being trained in many ways i
couldn't there was no check the games occult artifacts and
trips to the petting zoo that could be bought with that pot
assassination camp for kids damn this is gonna be good
that's some black widow i'm also all agamorph mostly yeah
i'm not oh is that right there you know well re-raise I'll
call.
Queen and seven.
He has a pair.
Wait, strong... Max has nothing.
It's strong bad versus Tycho.
Tycho.
I like how that was still censored.
Oh, he out.
Tycho has two pair.
Max has two pair.
Strong bad has two pair.
Yeah, Max out.
I was holding the cards that time.
Oh, that's fine.
Max is out.
That's good.
Well, it's like flint paper always says.
When you run out of money, it's time to go crack some
skulls.
I like this flint paper.
Max is out.
He lost his edge.
There's still chance.
Crap.
Let's do this guys all folded instantly.
Damn, you want to check let's go Oh shit, okay check city
USA I'll check as well.
God you're here
Checking this nine ten queen king I Need a Jack I
need a Jack the I'll check Oh, oh, okay, I check I bet The
player has a pair of aces Taiku has a pair of six Get out of
here That's right Or just I got the ace the player wins the
hand how much money I only get a thousand six hundred though
that shit is nothing that's nothing though we got we have to
knock out i bet you tyko was spy all alive he wearing a blue
shirt blue spy is blue coincidence i'm raising this hat
total man okay me versus strong bad okay one pair i'll check
move i'll toss a few chippies into the pot chippie chippie
i'll raise them and not even care a nerd rancher i'll raise
i'll raise your weight raise i don't really pay attention to
that sort of thing a couple million ha right i get it a few
blood jillian like on monday i'm sure you got seven
cotillion hits and on tuesday like half a blazillion
Those weren't even real numbers, you just said.
They'll use the head.
Nice!
Those weren't even real numbers, you just said.
That's right.
I'm not the only one making up numbers.
Okay.
Oh, God.
I need to make sure nobody knocks Strong Bad out, though.
So does our website, Bozo.
What does your sitter have?
You don't?
A couch.
I'll fold.
This was...
You better not knock out Strong Bad.
You better...
Oh, no, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
What was my hand?
Yeah, I was nothing.
Oh, my God.
Strong bad.
Do not get knocked out.
I swear to God.
Call your micro wager.
Strong bad.
I swear to God.
Don't get knocked out.
Strong bad.
I need that.
I need those glasses.
I need anything.
I do not know.
I have nothing.
What do you mean stay?
If that was an eight, then I regret everything.
I am folding.
Oh no, come on Tycho.
Tycho.
No.
Come on.
Do not.
King.
Nine.
He had nothing.
Nine, eight, nine, ten.
Queen.
Oh!
Strong bad heads are straight.
Oh, thank God.
Yes!
Oh, yeah.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
He had a straight.
It feels so much cooler to slip over my cards to win all the
big ones.
Oh, thank God.
Saved.
Actual saved.
Strong bad lives.
I'll try for this.
This could be salvageable.
I go all in.
All in?
I'm out.
Two pair, I'll call.
We don't even know what card that's on there.
He doesn't even know either.
We're both playing with luck today.
Okay.
Very bad.
I have a pair.
Three of a kind.
Goodbye, heavy.
Goodbye.
Three of a kind.
Oh, Sayonara.
The heavy has a pair of sevens.
The player has three of a kind.
The player wins the hand.
You have these big man cards.
Okay, we gotta get rid of Tycho.
I eliminated from play.
I am defeated.
This reminds me of famous song from Motherland.
You must know when to hold on to your cards and you must
know when to burn them in fire because if you lose, you
bring insufferable shame to them.
Is this a real song?
I will not be surprised if that was a real song.
300, 600.
Alright.
Oh no, he has to work in the forest now.
You guys keep playing cards and I'll keep thinking about
playing cards.
Okay.
I'll call.
I can't check so I'll call.
You have a pair of J's.
I'll check.
Let's make this a little interesting, shall we?
Okay.
You know what?
I'll raise then.
That's fine.
Two pairs.
I'll bet.
I'm cool.
I'll raise two.
Get out of here.
Get out.
All right.
We're just...
gotta make sure he has he has to fold out raise anything you
know even remotely interesting with hands like that you mean
besides punching your groin face in the face groin I mean
let's say you somehow get an opportunity with the ladies oh
man I'm so sorry this is gonna make you cry because I'm all
in oh you're all in yeah yeah no I call it I call it strong
man what about the bra factor how do you work the class this
is it This is it.
This is it.
No nines, no nines.
No nines, no nines, no nines, no nines, no nines, no nines,
no nines.
No nines.
Yes!
Three of a kind!
Those glasses are mine!
That's right.
Hand him over.
That's fucking right.
Get out of here.
Those shades are mine, baby.
Looks like you're going to have to jump into a hot new look
with this brand new pair of dangerous shades.
You will always look and feel your best.
Damn fucking right, I will.
Fun swords to Sam and Max stream.
Max needs it after losing so much.
Knock those.
Thank you.
The super chat.
Are they fun?
What type of game are they?
I've never played- I've always seen about it, but I've
never, like, played it before.
I'll raise.
I don't care about checking.
Time to fight the cheater.
I'll check.
I'm betting.
I don't- I don't feel confident with these cards.
I'll call.
Ah!
These cards are ass.
Oh, it's a point-and-click adventure?
Stealth Shako for two refined.
Patras, did they give us Super Chat?
thing you up love i'm outy 5000 yes i knew it i knew you
were always a coward you're all the same
i'll call heck city usa i can't check yeah ah two three four
i need five check i need a five i'll bet i'll call that i'm
good I'll check.
Ah!
Check disc.
That's nothing.
I can make him fold, though.
I'll make him fold.
I'm raising.
Oh, shit.
I'll raise again.
I'm raising.
I fold.
There we go.
That's right.
I know what you are.
You're a pussy.
With that turtleneck.
At poker night.
Let's do this.
The mind games.
Wow.
Yeah, I'll raise.
I'll do it.
Don't raise that.
I'm here to fuck with him.
in his head i'm nothing i feel like origami huh no it's not
worth it it's not worth it ds on and you guys keep giving oh
my god cannot wait to beat you okay
I'll call Okay, I raise
I'll call I have nothing I bet I have nothing
Papa, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you The
worst thing that ever happened Was Doki learning, bullying
is a valid Poker strategy Thank you for the super chat Thank
you, thank you I'll call his blow Yeah, I'm all in.
He's calling me high, Bluff.
Don't keep her in more like, do you keep her?
Hot got him.
Zero, thank you for the machete, the super.
Thank you.
I'll match it.
Oh, he had nothing, too.
He had nothing, too.
Oh, shit.
We both have nothing.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, wait.
Hell no.
Yes.
Aiku has queen high.
Ace is high.
I just, yes.
I just knew it.
Let it ride.
He called my bluff.
I call yours.
I know that he is stronger.
Let's go.
That's fucking right.
Bam.
I got the Team Fortress 2 deck.
Wait, I want to see what the cards look like.
Yeah, I might have had nothing, but my nothing was better.
Oh, that's sick.
There's a team of two cards.
Ace is high.
Oh, that's sick.
Oh.
I am going to play this one.
What weapon do you carry?
I'm gonna call it here, guys, because we do have a second
stream later.
That was fun.
Learning poker.
That was really fun.
Learning poker for the first time.
Look at that.
You guys dialed in me.
You all dialed in me, chat.
I was a baby, and now I'm the master.
I got the shades.
You being gambling.
in game in team i'd never done it myself i knew i had it in
me i knew it fake it till you make it you know that's right
they couldn't read me i was a blank slate they didn't know
what my tells were anyway guys i'm gonna call here we do
have another stream later tonight um at in three hours We're
going to be at the Doki SMP.
I'm not sure exactly.
I think I'm going to be touring around the buildings, and
I'm going to open the server.
The server will be closed when I'm touring the builds, but
then I'll open the server back up later up on stream,
because I have a little fun project that we could do
together.
Anyway, is it in three hours?
Let me double check the schedule.
Because I know we have the Doki SMP tonight.
Yeah, in three hours, the Doki SMP.
I'll make the waiting room for that.
Actually, yeah, I'll make the waiting room for that later.
Anyway, guys, I hope you guys had fun watching.
I really had a lot of fun learning poker and you guys
teaching me how to play poker.
I think I, I mean, I started, I started getting it.
I, you know, after Max defeated me there, it laid a fire in
me.
I was like, never again, Rabbit.
And now he was, he was always, he always got knocked out
ever since.
I was like, never again will this rabbit get me.
As always, everybody, stay hydrated, posture check, get a
moon right around to get that blood flowing.
And you stay up for me, head to bed, because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys later tonight or tomorrow, everyone.
Bye, guys.
Bye.